das woran ich alles gesetzt habe es zu
vermeiden das ist jetzt geschehen
ich habe kroner und als risikopatient
mit asthma ist das nichts was ich auf
die leichte schulter nehmen könnte und
was sowieso niemand auf die leichte
schulter nehmen sollte
denn ich habe die korona ringen absolut
streng ausgelegt habe immer abstand
gehalten maske getragen und habe sehr
sehr selten menschen getroffen und da
auch immer den nötigen abstand gehalten
sprich bei mir zeigt sich auf
beeindruckende weise um wie viel die
neue britische variante gefährlicher
geworden ist deshalb ist dieses video
auch eine warnung klicks uns im flugzeug
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur durch passt
hier nicht haben sich willkommen wir
können wir übrigens hier sehr gerne
fragen stellen ich werde sie in einem
ausführlichen podcast alle beantworten
also falls ihr es noch nicht gemacht
habt dann findet ihr den link zum
podcast hier und ami und in der video
beschreibung wer hier auf klicks um die
berichterstattung über corona verfolgt
hat der war wahrscheinlich mit am besten
über die pandemie informiert vor allem
in der zeit als corona noch nicht in
aller munde war ich habe hier als eines
der ersten medien darüber berichtet dass
das wahrscheinlich und zwar sehr
wahrscheinlich an der pandemie werden
würde
ich habe mit als erstes die hohe
sterberate thematisiert was mir das
prädikat panikmache von wallis
eingebracht hat richtig dramatisch wird
es dann bei youtube a und expedia graf
babysitter christoph krachten der macht
auf seinem kanal clixoom unter
rechenspiele lediglich zwei prozent
überleben die infektion nach dem
jetzigen stand nicht allerdings wenn die
ausbreitung nicht gestoppt werden kann
dann können das in deutschland um die
eine million menschen sei aber es ist
alles genau so gekommen
sprich mindestens so viele tote drohen
uns wenn wir nicht impfen und den
lockdown beibehalten auch als ich vorher
gesagt habe dass die krankenhäuser nicht
überfüllt werden was andere medien
wiederum ohne die nötige faktenlage
behauptet hatten am anfang der pandemie
habe ich auch regelmäßig aus meiner
selbstisolation berichtet die ich
gewählt hatte weil ich als asthmatiker
zur risikogruppe gehören und was heute
als bahnbrechende neuerungen gefeiert
wird das wurde bereits damals schon klar
und ich konnte meine selbst kann
eine verlassen asthmatiker sind nämlich
besonders geschützt zum einen gibt es
deutlich weniger asthmakranke unter
denjenigen die auf der intensivstation
wegen corona behandelt werden müssen als
vermutet wurde
und zum anderen scheinen die kortison
präparate an wirklichen wirksames
medikament gegen profit 19 zu sein
es wurde schon damals vermutet dass die
inhalte dass spike protein ac2 an den
menschlichen zellen in der lunge
deaktivieren und zu verhindern dass das
saas koch 2 virus überhaupt an den
zellen andocken kann jeden morgen und
jeden abend in all ihre ich ein solches
präparat und es ist davon auszugehen
dass es bisher schwere symptome
verhindert hat aber dass ich mich trotz
des inhaltes und trotz der minutiösen
einhaltung der abstandsregeln angesteckt
habe das ist beunruhigend
ich habe jetzt seit freitag 19 da habe
ich ein nettes gemacht und der war
positiv seitdem befinde ich mich in
quarantäne und am samstag habe ich dann
einen pcr tests gemacht der auch positiv
war
dann habe ich mein ergebnis in die
korona app eingetragen jetzt werden
meine kontakte vor allem geringen risiko
gewarnt weil ich ja nie länger als 15
minuten mehr als zwei meter in der nähe
eines anderen menschen war es gab eine
berufliche begegnung mit vorherigen
negativen schnelltest aber die ist schon
gecheckt und diese beiden kollegen sind
weiterhin negativ so dass sie sich nicht
angesteckt haben und ich mich auch nicht
bei ihnen angesteckt haben kann
nach jetzigem stand und das verunsichert
mich doch sehr ich habe mich
offensichtlich unter umständen
angesteckt die korona konform sind
sprich trotz abstand trotz nur kurzen
begegnungen habe ich mich angesteckt die
britische variante b 1 punkt 1.7 ist
damit nicht nur die dominierende
variante in deutschland das bedeutet
auch dass die abstandsregeln für sie
überhaupt nicht ausreichend denn wenn
diese variante deutlich ansteckender als
die urform ist warum gelten dann immer
noch 15 minuten und anderthalb meter als
sicher auch in der korona app soll ich
nur kontakte aufführen denen ich mehr
als zwei meter war und dass für 15
minuten
die gibt es aber außer meinen beiden
beruflichen kontakten die auch am
samstag noch per schnelltest negativ
waren nicht sie können mich also nicht
angesteckt haben aus als hätte eine sehr
unglückliche überlappung von
unterschiedlichen inkubationszeit
gegeben was schon
extrem unwahrscheinlich ist oder es gibt
verläufe die nie symptome entwickeln und
damit der schnelltest auch nie
anschlagen wird und das ist ja etwas was
ich bereits angekündigt hat ohne
symptome ist der schnelltest negativ die
bittere wahrheit über den schnelltest
wer nicht hustet oder sonstige symptome
hat der bekommt auch kein positives
testergebnis des corona tests wobei ich
muss auch festhalten
meine symptome ich habe nur
kopfschmerzen bisher traten einige
stunden nach dem schnelltest auf dazu
kommt in der korona waren app gibt es
keinerlei risiko begegnungen also bei
mir in der app als das finde ich
wirklich alarmierend zusammengefasst
selbst wenn man alle regeln minutiös
befolgt und auf alles achtet kann man
sich anstecken ich wäre jetzt überhaupt
nicht spekulieren
ich kann nur sagen dass meine
begegnungen form einer ansteckung immer
sehr distanziert waren auf der straße
hüpfe ich manchmal richtig rum um
niemanden zu nahe zu kommen bleibe
stehen und warte bis engpässe wieder
frei sind und so weiter und so fort denn
ich wollte wirklich wirklich verhindern
dass sich corona bekomme und ich bin
wirklich enttäuscht mich so co2 einer
möglichen impfung angesteckt zu haben
deshalb kann ich nur warnen vor allem
risikogruppen offensichtlich reichen die
geltenden corona regelungen nicht für
die virusvariante b 1 1 7 aus man sollte
wirklich über vorsichtig sein denn auch
wenn der verlauf bei mir milde ist
bisher die intensivstation laufen voll
weil die politik offensichtlich nicht in
der lage ist wirklich effektiv
durchzugreifen und taktische erwägungen
in richtung bundestagswahl eine größere
rolle spielen als menschen leben
ich will ja nicht für irgendeine
maßnahme partei ergreifen aber wenn sich
der berliner senat bewusst gegen die
empfehlung der wissenschaft entscheidet
und hier die intensivbetten nicht mehr
reichen dann ist das ganz schlimmes
politikversagen das menschenleben kostet
und an dieser stelle zum wiederholten
male wenn gegen fakten gehandelt wird
dann muss man als
wissenschaftsjournalist position
beziehen und die dinge beim namen nennen
und das werde ich immer wieder bei
themen wie klimawandel elektromobilität
corona und so weiter und so fort machen
denn es gibt nur einen weg zur
erkenntnis erkennen und dafür hat die
menschheit methoden entwickelt die
wiederum auf erkenntnissen basieren man
nennt es wissenschaft alles andere sind
mythen und fantasie und führen uns ins
mittelalter wie das auch jetzt ganz
konkret politische entscheidungen tun
die nicht auf der fakten
basieren wer fragen dazu und dem ganzen
themenkomplex hat stellt sie hier unter
dem video
ich beantworte sie alle in einem podcast
spezial der link ist hier und ami und in
der video beschreibung ich sehe
jedenfalls die konsequenzen und trete in
der nächsten zeit etwas kürzer und ich
habe jemanden ganz phänomenalen gefunden
der mich ja auch in der vergangenheit
schon mal vertreten hat tim von astor
comics tv hammer kanal mit vielen coolen
videos rund um den weltraum
tim wird hier jetzt also öfter zu sehen
sein wenn er ihn noch nicht abonniert
haben
der link kommt gleich hier vielen dank
dass du mir hier unter die arme greift
und hier abonnieren nicht vergessen das
mache ich natürlich sehr gerne und ihr
könnt euch auf einige abgefahrene themen
hier in den nächsten tagen bei klicks um
freuen zb im nächsten video
da wird christoph sogar noch mit dabei
sein denn es geht um sein neues buch
richtig gehört schon wieder ein neues
buch und das thema dieses buchs das
werden wir euch dann vorstellen
und falls sie es unwahrscheinlicher
weise noch nicht getan habt dann
abonniert doch sehr gerne auch meinen
channel astro comics tv im neuen video
erfahrt ihr alles über den ersten
helikopter flug auf dem mars super
spannendes thema ansonsten würde ich
sagen wir sehen uns im nächsten video
bis dann dann bleibt